bonjour leslie alors vous êtes donc sur
place on se dirige donc vers un nouveau
gouvernement indépendantiste c'est bien
cela et oui car les indépendantistes
obtenu la majorité absolue les électeurs
ont choisi les 135 députés maintenant ce
sont à ces derniers d'investir le
président alors les deux partis
indépendantistes sont au coude à coude
la gauche indépendantiste eux remporté
33 sièges et la droite indépendantistes
remportent 32 sièges à leurs a priori ça
sera la gauche indépendantiste qui
légèrement en tête prendrait la
présidence mais le parti sera soutenu
par le parti de droite de carless
puis-je démente qui lui est en faveur
d'un affrontement plus radicale avec
madrid
alors les indépendantistes se félicite
de ce résultat durant toute la campagne
électorale les deux parties ont indiqué
qu'ils allaient former un cordon
sanitaire autour du socialisme qui lui
est en faveur de l'unité de l'espagne
alors l'autre surprise de ce scrutin
c'est le score du socialiste salvadori
là et oui car le socialiste salvador ria
remporte le plus de suffrages il
remporte 33 sièges mais il est peu
probable qu'il trouve le soutien
nécessaire pour former un gouvernement
puisque le scénario le plus probable est
donc que la gauche indépendantiste
forment une alliance avec la droite
indépendantiste alors toutefois salvador
riaa a d'ores et déjà annoncé son
intention de se présenter à
l'investiture pour la présidence de la
catalogne car les socialistes aimerait
bien pouvoir prendre le pouvoir en
catalogne alors sans majorité il est
plus probable qu'ils voient leur plan b
c'est à dire voir la gauche
indépendantiste prendre le pouvoir mais
c'était quand même un très bon résultat
un très bon score pour salvadorien
puisqu'il double le nombre de sièges du
parti socialiste au parlement alors
leslie le scrutin est également marquée
par la montée de la droite radicale
et oui c'est un véritable tremblement de
terre l'extrême droite de vox siègera au
parlement catalan et c'est une première
car box est l'un des grands gagnants de
ce scrutin puisque l'autre surprise
c'est qu'il se hisse devant la droite
traditionnelle et conservatrice du
partido popular car sivok ce scrutin
après scrutin enchaîne les percées
électorales en espagne c'est bien la
première fois qu'il se glisse donc
devant la droite du parti
le populaire alors le parti de vote
représentera la quatrième force au
parlement catalan et son mot d'ordre est
simple mettre fin au processus
indépendantiste alors cette élection a
été particulière comment s'est organisée
ce vote en pleine pandémie alors de
strictes mesures sanitaires ont été
appliquées tout au long de la journée
afin de pouvoir permettre aux catalans
de voter les bureaux de vote étaient
limités à 500 électeurs et pour
permettre la distance sociale de
nouveaux bureaux de vote ont été ouverts
par exemple des gymnases bibliothèque et
marché couvert ont été habilités le
temps d'une journée
il y avait également des horaires
réservées à différents collectifs alors
de 9 heures à midi c'était pour les
personnages et les personnes à risques
puis 2010 à 19h c'était pour le reste de
la population
et enfin de 19 heures à 20 heures
c'était pour les personnes infectées par
le col vite 19 mais aussi les personnes
en quarantaine et les cas contacts alors
à l'intérieur les assesseurs avaient
toutes les protections donc masques
gants visière et même une combinaison
spéciale pour cette dernière heure alors
malgré toutes ces précautions le taux de
participation lui est en baisse en
comparaison avec 2010 est il a atteint
seulement les 52%
merci beaucoup les slips ou toutes ces
précisions leslie singla en direct
depuis barcelone